bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct je suis ravie de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir 50 industriels les
plus polluants du pays convoqués à
l'Elysée le chef de l'État de retour de
la COP 27 en Égypte les a convoqué pour
accélérer leur décarbonation il faut
dire que le temps presse alors comment
faire plus vite et plus fort jusqu'où
l'État peut aider les industriels et
peut-on empêcher les délocalisations
face au coût massif de la transition le
protectionnismement débat ce soir dans
un instant avec nos invités qu'est-ce
qu'être un grand préfet notre grand
témoin ce soir prend la plume pour
rendre hommage à cette fonction majeure
de la République fonction qu'il a exercé
de Paris à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon en
passant par la Guadeloupe ou encore la
Haute-Savoie comment garder la foi dans
le sens de l'État quand les services
publics craquels de toutes parts
Jean-François Carenco actuel ministre
des outre-mer et notre invité ce soir
enfin nos parties pris trois affranchis
ce soir vu du perchoir d'abord avec Elsa
mon dingava ce soir une ministre accusée
de conflits d'intérêts en Espagne rue
nacher c'est défendu à l'Assemblée vous
l'entendrez Jean-Rémy Beaudot nous dira
pourquoi l'état de nos armées est
inquiétant à la veille de la revue
stratégique et d'Emmanuel Macron et puis
la carte blanche elle a fait ministre
Léa chamboncelle ce soir la riposte des
influenceuses victimes de
cyber-harcèlement voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
Saint-Gobain Air Liquide les ciment
Lafarge la métallurgie la chimie à elle
seule elle représente les industriels
les plus polluants de France 10% de
l'ensemble des gaz à effet de serre émis
par tout le pays Emmanuel Macron leur
donne 18 mois pour agir mais sans
véritable compte bonsoir et bienvenue
Jean-Marc voulait dire vous sortez tout
juste de l'Élysée vous étiez conviés à
cette grande réunion avec les
industriels députés renaissance des
Bouches du Rhône vous présidez la
commission développement durable à
l'Assemblée nationale ici même bonsoir
Aurélie trouvée bienvenue à vous député
la France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis
ancienne
co-présidente et porte-parole du
collectif attaque bonsoir Nicolas
Broutin ravi de vous accueillir
président de Yara France gara France
c'est le Yara c'est le premier
producteur d'engrais en France et il
s'agit d'une multinationale on peut dire
ça oui dont le siège est en Norvège vous
allez nous expliquer je trouve ça vous
aussi vous faisiez partie de ce grand
Raoul à l'Élysée parmi donc les 50
industriels polluants en France invitée
Anaïs voi jelly spécialiste des enjeux
industriels avec une approche
géographique territoriale elle est
docteur en géographie à nous rejoindre
dans un instant mais tout ça c'est après
le billet de Blacko qui va nous planquer
planter le décor comme chaque soir si
j'ai bien compris ces donnant-donnant
pour Macron on voit ça tout de suite
avec avec valider
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam
en ce moment le président de la
République s'affiche à nouveau en
champion de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique on l'a vu la
cop27 en Égypte il n'a pas hésité à
montrer du doigt la Chine et les
États-Unis à peine revenus en France il
a convoqué l'Elysée 50 responsables des
sites industriels les plus polluants en
termes de CO2 pour leur mettre la
pression et vous y étiez d'ailleurs
c'est une manière de les montrer du
doigt clairement ou pas ah bah c'est le
fameux name and shame vous savez on
essaie de désigner publiquement les
mauvais élèves je ne vous regarde pas
pour leur mettre la honte devant
l'opinion les inciter à changer mais je
crois pas que ce soit vraiment ça que
vous voulez faire le président en tout
cas ça serait à mon avis un peu hein
juste quand on regarde depuis 30 ans le
secteur de l'industrie qui est quand
même celui qui a fait le plus d'efforts
vous voyez pour réduire quand même
beaucoup plus que les autres secteurs
elle n'empêche que c'est 56 produisent à
eux seuls on le disait
[Musique]
compliqué vous voyez c'est marqué dans
Les Echos notre quotidien économique La
crise énergétique fait que plutôt que
d'investir en ce moment les industriels
sont demandés s'ils vont pas de voir
vous me direz bon fermez des usines
après tout ce que c'est pas ça la
solution si il y a plus d'usine il y a
plus d'émission donc mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment ce qu'on veut faire en
France même les plus Paul Valentin le
président de la République au contraire
veut réindustrialiser
en ce moment ça pose problème le
ministre de l'Économie et Bruno Le Maire
est inquiale parler hier dans 4
quotidiens économiques européens en
disant qu'il y avait un risque de
décrochage de l'industrie et donc il
explique le problème est double quand on
prend les États-Unis c'est qu'il y a
d'une part le prix du gaz qui est en
Europe et 5 fois plus cher qu'aux
États-Unis et ça ajoute à ça le fait que
le Joe Biden cet été fait un truc qui
s'appelle la
je vais le lire
en fait qui sont 370 milliards de
subventions en industrie 370 ce qu'il
faut la France résultat le président
Macron était plutôt fâché tout à l'heure
on l'écoute on a aujourd'hui au fond un
double effet les États-Unis sont
producteurs
d'un gaz peu cher qui nous vendent cher
et en plus de ça il a pris les
dispositifs d'aide d'État massif sur
certains secteurs qui sortent
complètement nos projets du marché je
pense que ça n'est pas conforme aux
règles de l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce et je pense que ça n'est pas
amical ce n'est pas amical 69
pour illustrer le propos du présent je
vous donne deux exemples récents dans
l'actualité safran qui fabrique des
freins pour avion ou northwalk est un
Suédois qui fabrique des batteries tous
les deux avec des projets là en
Allemagne là en France et ben avec la
crise ils sont en train de se dire non
on va plutôt aller aux États-Unis ou
l'énergie est moins cher et où il y aura
des subventions et donc du coup en
Europe on essaie de lutter contre ça
notre commissaire Thierry Breton a écrit
à la Maison Blanche en écoute
d'injonction donc qui a été envoyé donc
aux Etats-Unis avec des points très
précis et donc ou bien il les règlements
ils vont les régler et on espère qu'ils
vont les régler donc c'est pour ça qu'il
y a cette plateforme pour discuter ou
bien il faudra aller devant le MC et on
va envisager évidemment des mesures de
rétention pour moi
européenne
pour rester unie
fortifications
qui a filé direct en Chine tout seul
pour avoir une relation privilégiée avec
ses INPI donc forcément ça met un petit
coup à l'unitaire européenne donc voilà
on est là comment décarboner sans
délocaliser comment réduire les
émissions sans réduire la production
c'est pas facile je sais pas si vous
avez les solutions mais c'est pas facile
merci placo débat merci beaucoup
Stéphane avec ce billet d'humeur
toujours aussi complet il y a beaucoup
d'éléments dans ce qu'a dit Stéphane on
va reprendre les choses dans l'ordre
d'abord un point de méthode Nicolas
Broutin vous vous étiez comment vous
avez vécu au fond cette démarche de
réunir les industriels est-ce que vous
vous êtes senti pointé du doigt de
retour d’égypte le président de la
République qui décide comme ça de
dresser la liste des 50 pollueurs en
France ou au contraire ça n'avait rien
d'un tribunal alors je n'ai pas reçu de
convocation j'ai reçu une invitation
et puis il y avait un contexte
préparatoire assez Réunion c'est à dire
qu'on a travaillé avec le ministre
auparavant donc en tant qu'industriel
non pas du tout enfin la réunion était
placée sous le signe des solutions
sous le signe de la réindustrialisation
donc de l'avenir et clairement aucun
problème avec la méthode en ce qui
concerne il y aura et je peux peut-être
rapidement revenir sur nos activités
aucun problème puisque la décarbonation
c'est quelque chose qu'on a commencé
depuis très longtemps
sur les trois sites que nous avons en
France on a déjà un résultat de l'ordre
de deux tiers d'abattement c'est à dire
que depuis la construction des trois
usines nous avons puisque vous y venez
expliquez-nous donc la production
d'engrais principalement chimique donc
polluants des engrais qui émettent un
CO2 parfois même on parle de N2O
encore plus polluant que que le dioxyde
de carbone comment on fait pour pour
empêcher ça pour se passer de cette
pollution là on va essayer de faire un
peu de chimie simple c'est à dire que la
fabrication des engrais azotés notamment
fait appel au gaz naturel le gaz naturel
contient du carbone ce que nous
utilisons dans le gaz naturel c'est
d'hydrogène donc le carbone est
effectivement rejeté il y a un autre
aspect dans la fabrication des engrais
c'est que nous avons besoin d'acide
nitrique pour leur fabrique pour leur
fabrication et l'acide nitrique les
ateliers d'acide nitrique sont des
émetteurs comme vous l'avez dit de N2O
donc de protoxyde d'azote c'est pas bon
du tout ça alors le protoxyde a un
pouvoir réchaud de réchauffement 300
fois supérieur au CO2 mais c'est sur le
protoxyde d'azote que des efforts
considérables ont déjà été faits vous
l'avez vu sur la courbe qui a été montré
si l'industrie a réduit considérablement
ses émissions durant les dernières
décennies c'est notamment parce que nous
avons des systèmes de catalyse sur ces
ateliers d'acide nitrique qui nous ont
permis quasiment d'atteindre zéro
émission alors vous allez nous dire on a
le temps on termine le tour de table
vous allez nous dire comment vous y
prenez est-ce que vous êtes impacté de
façon extrêmement dure par la crise
énergétique est-ce que vous avez besoin
et de combien d'argent public parce que
c'est la question de savoir si c'est
suffisant ou pas Jean-Marc je vous l'ai
dit vous y étiez aussi n'empêche que la
liste elle est dans les médias
aujourd'hui c'est pas bon pour l'image
d'une entreprise d'être comme ça de
jeter un peu en pâture 50 industrie site
industrielle polluant est-ce que c'est
c'est de la solidarité industrielle de
faire ça l'idée c'est avant tout de
travailler main dans la main avec les
industriels on a une volonté qui est
très simple qui est exprimée par le
Président de la République c'est de
d'accélérer nos réductions de
d'émissions de CO2 et pour cela et bien
on réunit les industriels 50 sites 43
millions de tonnes de CO2 et on se met
autour de la table pour une méthode et
cette méthode a été très clairement
prononcée par le président il s'agit de
dans les six mois à venir de mettre en
place le contrat de transition
écologique directement dans les
territoires de mettre 5 milliards de
plus en plus du plan France 2030
permettant justement d'accélérer cette
décarbonation et de dire clairement que
nous croyons dans l'industrie il y a
beaucoup de milliards c'est compliqué
pour ce qui nous regardent France galets
européenne il y a la possibilité de
doubler de 5 à 10 les investissements
français ça c'est sans l'aide européenne
c'est notamment donc on est à combien au
tout 13 milliards 15 milliards de 15
milliards d'euros permettant justement
d'avancer et de préserver une industrie
c'était important aussi de dire que nous
croyons dans l'industrie tout à l'heure
lorsque on disait ce que la solution
c'est de fermer tes usines non c'est pas
la solution parce que je le dis souvent
au-delà de l'aspect technologique
technique industrielle il y a une vraie
dimension politique fermer une usine
c'est ouvrir une permanence
parlementaire rassemblement national je
le dis ce que nous avons vécu cet
après-midi c'est investir avant tout
dans l'avenir et faire confiance dans
l'innovation et les technologies
et sur le calendrier de mise en place de
tous ces plans de relance Aurélie
trouver il y a un mot dans la bouche du
président qui doit vous faire plaisir
c'est le mot de planification il a cessé
de répéter il a parlé d'une
planification des technologies de
décarbonation en parlant de l'hydrogène
en parlant de la biomasse en parlant de
séquestre le CO2 et il a parlé aussi
d'une planification territoriale avec
des milliards à la clé ça va dans le bon
sens d'abord il nous avait parlé il fut
un temps de planification démocratique
je vais vous dire qu'en tant que député
moi j'étais en travaux parlementaire
donc j'ai pas pu suivre la chaîne
Twitter de l'Elysée pour savoir ce qui
survint ans se dessine donc je suis
ravie d'apprendre en tant que député élu
pour représenter la nation ce qui se
trame sur 20 ans ce qui concerne un
enjeu fondamental de la nation donc je
le dis il y a déjà un énorme problème
démocratique vis-à-vis notamment de
l'Assemblée nationale j'aurais pensé
à l'assemblé oui mais tout ce qui là est
présenté sur la table n'a aucun moment
on aurait pu penser que l'Assemblée
nationale était d'abord avant les
entreprises
sollicité pour discussion je suis en
commission à faire économique ça aurait
dû être le cas ça n'est pas le cas dont
tac la planification démocratique de mon
point de vue déjà pose question ensuite
il faut une planification systémique et
je vais prendre l'exemple de Yara
l'émission la question l'entreprise des
missions il se trouve que voilà mon
métier était un Grenoble et que je suis
moi-même l'Académie d'Agriculture et ça
je connais très bien le dossier et le
secteur bon le problème sur les
émissions les émissions de protoxyde
d'azote liés aux engrais azotés le
problème n'est pas de décarboner tant la
production d'engrais azotées elle est de
diminuer la production d'engraisse au
thé et donc d'accepter de désinvestir de
ce secteur pour réinvestir par contre
dans d'autres secteurs de transition
écologique et c'est là le problème c'est
que la planification n'est pas
systémique parce que l'industriel de
changer d'activité en fait mais je pense
qu'une planification sur 20 ans c'est
d'accepter le GIEC les scientifiques du
GIEC le disent eux-mêmes les tous ces
experts sur le climat c'est qu'il faut
remettre en globalement notre mode de
production je prends cet exemple très
concret des engrais azotés ce que l'on
sait aujourd'hui c'est que pour diminuer
la production d'engraisse au thé et la
seule solution pour que tu n'aies pas
autant d'émission notamment quand on les
utilise et bien c'est de développer
massivement les légumineuses les
protéaginaux dans les sols excuse-moi je
fais un peu d'agronomie mais pour vous
montrer que c'est possible
d'utiliser davantage d'engrais
organiques
issus de l'élevage etc donc ces deux
planifier un plan beaucoup plus global
sur la sobriété dont il faut des
industries de demain et comment
excusez-moi comment reconverti
professionnellement avec de la formation
à la clé etc tous les employés et qu'on
réinceste là vous lancez tout de suite
sur de très long terme avec voilà le
méta vous allez répondre sur 20 ans on
m'a dit c'est vrai vous allez répondre
on va terminer quand même le tour de
table sur effectivement des alternatives
totalement voilà à l'activité même de
l'utilisation des engrais azotés bonsoir
Anaïs Gillis et merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes docteur en géographie
spécialiste des questions industrielles
on a la logique du donnant donnant
suffisamment incitatif ou pas selon vous
fallait-il plus de contraintes en fait
là on aborde une multitude de sujets
parce que on peut pas en fait ça relève
plein de choses il y a à la fois
l'aspect planification qui révèle de
notre ambition en termes de projet de
société et sur lequel on a vraiment pas
posé la question en terme de
développement industriel qu'on veut pour
le futur et c'est vrai que selon cette
ambition de société on va pas forcément
prendre les mêmes stratégies
industrielles et après il y a ce qui
relève de la décarbonation alors
peut-être pour les gens qui nous
écoutent moi je trouve que c'est négatif
de planter pointer un effet du doigt 50
personnes qui polluent parce que c'est
pas exactement que de la pollution on
est sur des émissions carbone on traite
pas le sujet de manière plus large sur
deux aspects c'est un pour que la
planète soit vivable en 2050 c'est pas
qu'un sujet décarbonation c'est un sujet
beaucoup plus large d'empreinte
environnementale comment réduit notre
empreinte environnementale comment on
travaille sur les charges qui ne sont
pas forcément maîtrise
acidification des océans et qui devrait
être traité avec au moins en temps
d'importance que la décarbonation je
pense qu'on a quand même une urgence là
on a des objectifs nationaux ne
serait-ce que sur une stratégie en fait
le problème c'est que ce qu'on comprend
pas c'est que focaliser notre énergie
sur la décarbonation qui est un enjeu
clé on oublie et beaucoup d'autres
sujets qui sont tout aussi clés ne
serait-ce que pour l'industrie
c'est-à-dire quand on parle de
sécheresse potentiellement on a des
sites industriels qu'on ne pourra plus
faire tourner dans les prochaines années
donc en fait il faut bien avoir
rejoignez là-dessus c'est l'approche
globale qui n'est pas au rendez-vous
l'approche globale enfin une approche
systémique et l'autre chose c'est qu'on
se focalise énormément sur les les sites
industriels et on n'a pas cette approche
globale chaîne de valeur c'est à dire
que j'ai des industries que je vais
pouvoir je décarboner le site c'est
important et si je prends l'exemple de
l'agriculture on a aussi un gros
problème qui se positionne sur l'amont
avec les émissions de méthane ce genre
de choses donc bien l'important d'avoir
ça et ensuite ce qui est important de
dire sur le sujet des carbonations c'est
oui il faut demander des garanties je
pense qu'il y a des choses des exigences
qui sont
deuxièmement une position qu'on assume
totalement c'est la position
d'intensification
un végétal c'est une usine à oxygène qui
absorbe du CO2 l'intensification de la
production végétale va totalement dans
le sens et c'est ce que fait
l'agriculture de d'avoir une solution de
grande ampleur pour la dégarbonation et
donc intensifier sur des hectares
restreints à plus de sens plutôt que
d'étaler une production extrêmement
extensive qui va mobiliser des terres
dont on a besoin et aujourd'hui
clairement quand vous intensifiez un
hectare de blé avec un engrais azotée
minérale vous pouvez à côté sauver
quatre hectares de forêt si vous le
menez bien la France comment vous faites
vous électrifiez la production
progressivement on a compris ce que vous
faites sur les engrais azotés mais
quelle est la stratégie des carbonations
sur l'ensemble de la production alors il
faut bien séparer de voler c'est à dire
que il y a la partie décarbonation à la
production je vous ai parlé protoxyde
d'azote c'est un problème aujourd'hui
qui est réglé et il faut dire que
l'industrie européenne et l'industrie
française sont à la pointe c'est-à-dire
que nulle part dans le monde vous avez
des industries qui décarbonent autant
sur ce sujet protoxyde il faut quand
même le rappeler il va nous rester
lamoniaque donc la fabrication
d'ammoniac émet du CO2 on a deux
solutions une première qui consiste à
capturer le CO2 de process et puis soit
le stocker soit l'utiliser dans d'autres
filières qui d'ailleurs vont pouvoir
produire des carburants l'autre option
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hydrogène vert
donc l'ammoniac vert ou la effectivement
on va parler l'électrification alimenter
des électrolyseurs et par électrolyse de
l'eau obtenir un hydrogène alternatif
pour ouvrir un peu parce qu'on va pas
rester uniquement sur votre activité
industrielle on parle beaucoup des
technologies des carbonations et le chef
de l'État a insisté en parlant de
l'hydrogène en parlant de la capture de
CO2 illustration justement avec la série
starcellor Mittal qui a entamé cette
transition grâce à cette technologie on
va se là avec Maïté vraiment
sur le site Deo fourneaux
d'ArcelorMittal dans le nord de la
France voici le démonstrateur de captage
de CO2 également appelé le piège à
carbone avec cette tour haute de 22
mètres le leader de la sidérurgie se
lance un défi
transformer son acier gris en acier vert
de manière très simplifiée d'accord vous
avez ce qu'on appelle une amine qui est
grosso modo une molécule proche d'un
solvant d'accord qui va être au contact
des fumées capter le CO2 on va reprendre
cette amine un autre endroit dans un
autre réacteur et là en chauffant en
fait le CO2 va se séparer donc on va
récupérer un CO2 extrêmement pur alors
qu'il était mélangé dans le reste de nos
fumées en d'autres termes dans ces
tuyaux on décarbonne si le démonstrateur
on parle de 4000 tonnes de CO2 par an
d'accord l'échelle industrielle c'est un
million de tonnes et au-delà l'objectif
d'ArcelorMittal et de réduire de 35% ses
émissions de CO2 d'ici à
à plus long terme une neutralité carbone
en 2050 l'enjeu est colossal 200 000
tonnes d'acier sont produits chaque jour
11 millions de tonnes chaque année
au-delà de ce projet ArcelorMittal
travaille sur quasiment toutes les
pistes possibles pour se décarboner
économie circulaire recyclage de la
ferraille ou encore production
d'électricité verte via l'hydrogène
on prend notre part on sait ce qu'il
faut faire pour atteindre cette
neutralité carbone en 2050 mais on aura
besoin pour y arriver du soutien des
politiques publiques que ce soit au
niveau européen au niveau national
toutes ces solutions auront un coup
pour l'heure harcelormittal investi en
France plus d'un milliard et demi sur 8
ans une enveloppe loin d'être suffisante
pour couvrir toutes ces transformations
voilà Jean-Marc zulezila on arrive au
nerf de la guerre c'est la question des
moyens on a un exemple ça a l'air de
marcher
ArcelorMittal est-ce que c'est l'exemple
à suivre on sait que l'entreprise est
dans le vaste plan hydrogène mais ça
reste trop peu et est-ce que vous croyez
pas que c'est un petit peu ce qui va se
passer pour l'ensemble des industries
c'est à dire on commence mais on peut
pas être au niveau demandé
à la capacité l'industrie de pouvoir
évoluer je crois que ce qui s'est passé
dans les 10 dernières années à montrer
que il y avait cette capacité de faire
évoluer des process les courbes que vous
avez montré tout à l'heure le montre
c'est à dire qu'ils ont comme aucun
autre secteur baissé leur émission
contrairement à payer cette transition
par exemple au secteur des transports on
doit absolument intensifier nos moyens
et donc à payer pour les industriels
c'est avant tout les entreprises ou
avant tout l'État je pense que ça doit
être du gagnant-gagnant donc les
industriels doivent prendre toutes leurs
parts dans la transformation de leur
process aider par la puissance publique
et je vous le dis de manière très
sincère je préfère que on accompagne ces
industriels sur notre territoire plutôt
que ces industriels partent et partent à
l'étranger
une petite question ni collabota sur les
10 milliards vous avez une toute petite
idée de du fléchage pour votre
entreprise où il y aura France comment
comment sont affectés les moyens sur
quoi vous vous pariez pour provisionner
des des fonds pour la décarbonation en
termes de solutions
dans un premier temps le président
Macron a donné six mois pour qu'on
établisse une feuille de route avec deux
éléments d'abord ce qu'il a appelé la
planification technologique mais en
termes est-ce que vous a laissé
comprendre comment serait les calculs
seraient faits ou ce sera le dossier ce
sera la résultante effectivement de ce
qui va du travail qui va être fait
pendant les six mois à venir Aurélie
trouvée c'est avant tout aux entreprises
de payer cette transition ou ça devrait
être 55 ans comment vous voyez ce ce
schéma là qui va prendre des années déjà
comme vous dites ça va prendre des
années mais surtout pour l'instant on
n'est pas au rendez-vous des engagements
la France ne respecte pas les
engagements fixés la trajectoire d'ici
2030 de réduction des gaz des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre - 55% d'ici 2030
mais là il y a 15 milliards deuxièmement
il y a un sondage Accenture fait un
rapport qui vient de montrer qu'il y a
que 9% des entreprises des plus grandes
entreprises en Europe qui respectent
leurs propres engagements donc on a un
vrai problème donc c'est bien d'être
optimiste maintenant il faut agir très
fermement et là il y a une différence
complète de de façon de faire de la
politique économique entre la minorité
présidentielle et ce que nous
représentons dans la nuit parce que nous
pensons que l'État que l'État doit
fermement doit réguler fermement ça
passe d'abord par des aides aux
résistance de perdre des emplois alors
je vais en parler sujet aussi d'abord
des aides massives c'est vrai il faut
des aides massives mais conditionnées je
rappelle que depuis 2005 par exemple il
y a eu on a offert à titre gratuit des
quotas de CO2 où est le résultat dès le
il y a 160 milliards à peu près d'être
public par an aux entreprises de manière
régale où est le résultat de la
reconversion écologique on a un vrai
problème je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
puis deuxièmement et bien peut-être que
dans des conseils d'administration de
certaines entreprises et bien il faut
que l'État revienne agissent que aussi
il y ait peut-être davantage de
représentants de salariés
dans certains pays pas forcément mais
changer le fonctionnement des Français
les conseils d'administration c'est quoi
ce sont des actionnaires qui ont un
intérêt c'est la rentabilité à court
terme des capitaux il y a pas c'est
comme ça bon c'est l'économie peut enfin
voilà c'est la base de l'économie la
question elle est comment l'État qui
représente quelques pouvoirs avec des
actions avec quelles participations il y
a des pays en par exemple il y a des
règles de représentation minimale des
salariés dans les conseils
d'administration on pourrait penser à ce
qui est des représentants des
collectivités locales des usagers et
puis l'état je veux dire historiquement
l'État était parti prenantes avant qu'on
des règles longtemps au capital on a eu
un simple rôle de contrôleur dans la ça
peut être dans le conseil
d'administration quand il le faut soit
sur des industries stratégiques elle
peut très bien prendre une part dans les
conseils d'administration et ensuite je
finis sur la question puisqu'on a parlé
de de Biden des États-Unis je vous
propose on va terminer
là-dessus nous sommes dans la nupette
pour la relocalisation de l'industrie
mais justement ça demande de remettre en
cause les dogmes d'une néolibéralisme
économique alors quand on regarde les
emplois industriels sur le voilà le long
terme si on prend depuis les années 80
c'est une destruction lente et
progressive de centaines de milliers
d'emplois donc c'est énorme mais c'est
vrai que ça repart plus de 34 000
emplois créés dans l'industrie en 2022
57000 depuis 2017 ça reste très très
fragile on entend hébronay le maire face
à la crise énergétique est-ce que
comment concilier à la fois la question
de l'emploi et la question de la
transition bon je crois pas que un tel
sujet nécessite des polémiques stériles
sur une minorité ou une majorité en tout
cas une chose est sûre répondait à
l'expression minorité présidentielle de
elle et en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est que sur le fond une chose est sûre
c'est que la politique est menée depuis
six ans permet justement de le
relocaliser un certain nombre
d'activités la politique qui est menée
en termes fiscal mais aussi grâce à ces
contrats de transition écologique
permettent à des entreprises de se
développer de se décarboner et ça c'est
une bonne chose et c'est une bonne chose
pour notre pays faut-il mettre en place
des contraintes la réponse est oui mais
à l'échelle européenne
illustration pour contrôler voir
l'échelle la taxation la taxation aux
frontières c'est la France qui l'a
portée ça sera acté et c'est une bonne
chose après je ne pense pas je ne pense
pas que ce soit à l'état de venir dans
des conseils
nous sommes dans une politique
économique qui est qui est ouverte mais
vous parlez des entreprises privées là
qui sont juste là EDF c'est un autre
sujet et vous le savez très bien
oui mais c'est un autre sujet donc si
vous voulez voilà donc oui mais si vous
voulez c'est très simple de poser des
amendements qui visent à racheter engie
en faisant croire aux gens qu'on peut
les acheter 10 millions d'euros comme
vous avez tenté de le faire il faut pas
raconter à raconter des bêtises aux gens
il faut aller sur le terrain et voir
typiquement comment une entreprise
fonctionne moi qui viennent de
l'industrie je peux vous dire que vous
êtes bien loin du fonctionnement de
l'entreprise tel que ça fonctionne au
quotidien alors on va regarder
maintenant les aides américaines et je
vous donne la parole dans un instant les
industriels sont plutôt attirés on l'a
dit par les Américains faut dire que le
montant du plan de relance dans
l'économie verte donne le vertige 370
milliards de dollars écoutez Joe Biden
soyons clairs ce projet de loi est la
législation la plus importante de
l'histoire pour s'attaquer à la crise
climatique et améliorer immédiatement
notre sécurité énergétique c'est un
outil pour atteindre les objectifs
climatiques que nous avons convenu en
réduisant les émissions et en accélérant
l'énergie propre c'est un énorme part en
avant voilà Bruno Le Maire qui réagisse
que propose les Américains et 4 à 10
fois le montant maximal autorisé par la
Commission européenne analyse voijili
c'est ce qu'il faut changer les règles
du jeu européenne est-ce qu'il faut
permettre des subventions publiques des
aides d'État européennes bien plus
importants pour faire un protectionnisme
aux frontières de l'Europe pour faire
face à la concurrence chinoise ou
américaine on dirait que certains
découvrent que les rapports de force
mondiaux ce n'est pas un monde de
bisounours c'est à dire que des aides
d'État des barrières non tarifaires et
une guerre commerciale ça fait quand
même quelques années qu'on le voit aussi
bien du côté de la Chine que des
États-Unis
aujourd'hui les États-Unis disposent
clairement d'un avantage compétitif avec
le prix un prix d'énergie
on est en fait on est dans une période
où il y a énormément d'argent public
dans le monde entier mis sur la table
parce que tout le monde a l'ambition de
réindustrialiser ce qui se passe c'est
que nous on a on est en train de perdre
notre avantage compétitif avec l'énergie
et donc on a des industriels qui vont se
détourner de nous dans cette période
d'investissement donc là on risque de
perdre 10 à 15 ans c'est à dire que si
les gens qui ont des projets
d'investissement en France ne le font
pas ou en Europe ne le font pas là on
perdit on prend 10 à 15 ans de retard
mais alors il y a quelques projets il y
a des giga projets par exemple les
gigafactory dans dans les
Hauts-de-France pour les batteries
électriques il y a une volonté de
reproduire en France regardez le lithium
qu'on va maintenant extraire il y a une
France est-ce que en France est-ce que
il y a une prise de conscience de
reproduire des industries en fait il y a
pas de doute sur une volonté politique
j'ai aucun doute là-dessus mais il y a
politique et il y a la réalité
il y a la réalité des entreprises donc
il y a un moment il faut arrêter d'être
les naïfs de la mondialisation ça veut
pas dire mais du protectionnisme à tout
va ça veut juste dire certains ne
respectent pas les règles
internationales du commerce dans ce
cas-là les produits n'ont pas le droit
de rentrer sur le territoire européen et
alors moi je me permets sur le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières dans
son état actuel il va juste être impact
carbone aux frontières de l'Europe c'est
ça exactement il va être un facteur de
désindustrialisation parce qu'il cible
quatre secteurs les engrais le ciment
l'acier et il m'en manque un mais c'est
pas très grave sur des matières
uniquement donc vous pouvez très
facilement le contourner en faisant
rentrer sur le territoire européen des
produits finis ou
semi-finis il y a des effets le ciment
est moins concerné parce que ça se
transporte pas facilement mais l'acier
voilà Nicolas Broutin
Joe Biden il se dit il se dit pas je
vais aller
simplement délocaliser aux États-Unis il
faut rappeler qu'on a une agriculture
une belle agriculture européenne une
très belle agriculture française donc la
France reste une puissance agricole de
premier ordre il est évident pour un
industriel comme ira c'est un pays très
important et on entend bien continuer à
mener des industries en France mais
quand vous écoutez les arguments il faut
arrêter d'être naïfs de la
mondialisation ou de la guerre
commerciale qu'est-ce que comment vous
réagissez d'abord le premier point c'est
que la discussion illustre que ça
dépasse l'entreprise et ça a été dit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il y a un
volet technologique et il y a un volet
territorial et on a bien vu la zone de
Dunkerque la zone de fosse la zone de
Rouen où ça dépasse l'industriel les
infrastructures qui va falloir
développer dépasse des capitaux privés
et demandent effectivement un soutien
plus large donc le rôle politique
m'apparaît évident que les hauts de
France où il y a justement ces
technologies pour expliquer qui
permettent de décarboner avec des
grosses usines et d'ailleurs même des
règles qui controviennent au traité avec
des projets franco-allemand qui
nécessitent plus d'argent que ne le
permettent les aides d'État donc il faut
changer les règles du jeu de plus en
plus en Europe pour pour permettre les
investissements à la hauteur un moment
donné ça dépasse l'entreprise privée en
termes d'investissement donc
effectivement une action quel montant
des dizaines de milliards
lors de la préparation on a évoqué la
question de la taxe carbone frontière on
a évoqué la question du marché du
carbone les entreprises pour des
carboner vont faire appel en partie à
cette technologie qui vise finalement un
capturer le CO2 à le liquéfier et puis
soit l'utiliser ou le stocker c'est un
coût ce coût bien aujourd'hui c'est le
cours représente à peu près 30% de plus
par rapport au marché actuel du carbone
donc il est évident économiquement si il
n'y a pas une prise en compte de cet
écart pour l'industriel c'est compliqué
d'investir
de façon
méta importante je peux prendre
l'exemple de la Norvège puisque en
Norvège on commencer l'électrification
complète de notre plus gros usine c'est
une démarche qui se fait avec un
accompagnement très forte très fort les
autorités figurer les choses on est sur
quelque chose de plus modeste
certainement à notre niveau mais on est
sur 250 à 300 millions d'euros pour une
usine pour une usine c'est un montant
qui est quand même assez courant chez
les électro intensifs ou les fortement
émetteurs de carbone on part vite sur du
entre 100 et 250 millions de
d'investissements est-ce qu'on peut
faire du protectionnisme sans changer
les règles Jean-Max zoologie en Europe
non mais si il y a un certain nombre de
règles à changer si vous voulez faire du
du protectionnisme les règles de chaque
de chaque pays sur cette la capacité sur
des tas notamment des États mais moi
c'est pas mon modèle de société je
considère que c'est pas à l'état d'être
présent dans toutes les entreprises mais
quand Emmanuel elle parle de
souveraineté européenne est-ce qu'elle
est compatible avec les traités elle est
compatible avec les avec les traités
encore faut-il qui est une entente entre
chaque pays européen permettant
d'avancer
ensemble et c'est ça l'enjeu Aurélie
trouver oui ben je pense qu'il faut un
protectionnisme effectivement
intelligent ça passe par à mon avis les
barrières non tarifaires c'est-à-dire
les règles environnementales notamment
faire en sorte que les règles
environnementales qui sont aujourd'hui
qui doivent être parce qu'elles ne sont
pas à mon avis suffisamment imposées en
Europe et bien le soit sur les produits
importés donc là il y a tout un tout un
arsenal à revoir mais il faut sortir de
l'idéologie néolibérale qui prévaut y
compris en France et donc et du coup on
arrêtera aussi ce qu'on cette naïveté et
ah oui Biden il ose bah oui en fait ça
fait longtemps que les États-Unis et la
Chine etc sont sortis des logis
néolibérale qui prévaut encore en Europe
ensuite ce qu'il faut faire c'est
surtout que les 160 milliards d'aide
publique distribuées aux entreprises en
France vraiment orientés vers les
secteurs d'avenir la rénovation
thermique des logements le transport
public etc qui permettent vraiment aussi
de diminuer la consommation d'énergie de
gestion de l'Industrielle oui mais je
rappelle que le premier poste parce
qu'on parle de relocalisation le premier
poste d'importation commerciale en
français l'énergie donc si on en veut
rétablir la balance commerciale ça passe
déjà par la sodomie avoir le mot de la
fin Anaïs veuille peut-être aussi que
c'est la flambée des prix de l'énergie
qui va pousser la transition aujourd'hui
la tonne de CO2 et moins cher face à
auprès du gaz qui flambe assurément ça
va pousser la transition c'est c'est clé
tout l'enjeu et d'arriver à garder les
industries sur le territoire et pour ça
il va falloir mettre des moyens de la
contrepartie et savoir où on va
collectivement voilà l'enjeu est immense
on l'a compris on espère que ceux qui
nous regardent ils voient un peu plus
clair ce soir merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat on va
présent accueillir notre grand témoin il
est aujourd'hui ministre des outre-mer
et témoignent dans un livre de son
parcours exceptionnel au service de
l'État en général les unarques font tout
pour éviter de finir préfet bah lui
c'était son rêve il prend la plume pour
rendre hommage à cette fonction majeure
de la République qui travers c'est de
Paris à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon en
passant par la Guadeloupe ou encore la
Haute-Savoie en accueille Jean-François
caraco juste après l'invitation signé ce
soir Marco 1er
si on vous invite Jean-François carinco
c'est pour revenir sur votre parcours de
haut fonctionnaire 25 années au service
de l'État et une carrière hors norme de
préfet que vous racontez dans un livre
un récit personnel l'occasion de lever
le voile sur un métier de l'ombre pour
faire ce métier il faut avoir trois
amours chevillés au corps les autres la
France et la République Jean-François
carinko vous êtes un enfant de cette
république vous le clamez ou effort et
en bon fils vous avez consacré votre vie
au service de l'État de la Guadeloupe à
Paris vous avez connu cinq présidents de
la République en tant que préfet proche
de la droite centriste vous avez œuvré à
trois reprises pour le ministre
Jean-Louis Borloz aujourd'hui c'est à
votre tour votre portefeuille
ministériel est réputé explosif celui
des Outre-mer dans vos dossiers les
difficultés d'accès à l'eau potable mais
aussi le sa vie pour vous entrez dans
l'arène politique c'est un honneur de la
République
servir l'outre-mer ses habitants
ça a toujours été ma passion et ma vie
nous remerde dans laquelle vous avez
appris votre métier de préfet une
fonction vénérable il remplaçable
dites-vous
âgés de plus de 200 ans c'était une
invention napoléonienne servir la
République pour un préfet c'est l'aimer
à prendre ce qu'elle est à travers son
histoire à travers les hommes et les
femmes qui la composent et quand la
République est menacée le préfet incarne
l'ordre et endosse la tunique répressive
comme un l'an 2000 la Pointe-à-Pitre où
vous ordonnez d'envoyer les gaz
lacrymogènes contre des manifestants qui
voulaient enfoncer la porte d'une prison
autre souvenir marquant l'évacuation de
milliers de migrants installés en plein
centre de Paris entre les insultes des
manifestants et les nuits de
journalistes vous faites votre devoir
malgré vos idéaux malmenées que dire
donc au président Hollande pour lui
rendre compte de cette mission rien je
suis arrivé devant lui
si troubler que je ne pouvais parler il
m'a simplement réconforté alors
Jean-François carinco à l'heure des
réouverture des sous-préfectures à
l'heure où Emmanuel Macron promet un
état plus fort se renforcement n'est-il
pas le signe d'un affaiblissement de la
République
à vous la parole
bonsoir Jean-François caraco et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on va
parler des Outre-mer dont vous avez la
charge au gouvernement depuis juillet
dernier mais on va commencer par votre
livre préfet de la République aux
éditions du Cerf et cette fonction de
préfet que vous aimez tant comment
garder la foi pour répondre à cette
question au fond dans dans le sens de
l'État quand les services publics
craquels de toutes parts il faut aimer
la France aimer les gens et savoir que
seule l'action compte en essayant de
différencier les réactions immédiates du
chemin qui est à suivre en même temps
les sous-préfectures pour vous c'est une
une bonne chose de les de les remettre
dans les territoires c'est pas aussi le
signe d'un délitement de devoir ramener
l'État au plus près au contraire je
crois pas je crois que la démocratie
c'est aussi l'état je rappelle qu'en
France c'est l'État qui a créé la nation
à la différence de ce qui se passe dans
tous les autres pays européens c'est
l'histoire c'est ni bien animal notre
République fondé sur l'état alors elle
doit évoluer elle doit faire participer
les gens elle doit écouter les élus mais
notre système depuis Jacques Coeur
fonctionne avec l'État c'est très
difficile à changer d'ailleurs c'est
Macron est un grand jacobin ou plutôt ou
plutôt Girondins mais qu'est-ce qu'être
préfère quel mot vous mettriez pour
traduire caractériser cette fonction
d'abord c'est peut-être le représentant
de l'État et de la nation le président
de la République au niveau national le
préfet les dans son territoire c'est le
premier sujet il incarne la nation il
incarne l'État et donc puisqu'il incarne
l'État et la nation a lui aussi de se
faire aimer alors se faire aimer ça veut
pas dire être béni oui et tout lâcher
mais à lui de montrer que ça va mieux
quand l'État est là et l'État et là pour
servir les autres il faut servir ça ça
revient tout le temps les autres la
France la République dans cet ordre là
d'abord les autres le pays et la
République c'est la même chose la même
chose en France
vous ne pouvez pas dire j'ai des
fonctions des responsabilités publiques
importantes incarner l'état incarné le
gouvernement aussi on est on est le
gouvernement dans les territoires c'est
le préfet il apprécient sur tout le
monde parce qu'il est le gouvernement il
coordonne voire commande l'action de
tous les services de l'État non vous
pouvez pas faire cela sans aimer ce que
vous faites ou alors vous êtes juste un
format
et franchement sur le fond vous l'avez
vous observé la République au plus près
des territoires dans les départements
aussi variés que la Haute-Savoie la
capitale la Guadeloupe
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon vous trouvez
franchement que les services publics
vont bien que la République va bien
aujourd'hui dans ce cas là justement à
offrir aux citoyens en termes de valeur
républicaine le sujet on est dans un
monde en crise crise de l'énergie crise
climatique terrible
évolution de système d'information avec
l'information en continu immédiate
il détruite etc
et on est dans un monde qui peut appeler
ce communautarisme l'isolationnisme le
communautarisme pour lutter contre pour
essayer de créer un avenir meilleur à
nos enfants il y a pas d'autres
solutions que la République je n'en vois
pas mais les services publics qu'ils
doivent incarner les valeurs de la
République sur le terrain sont-ils en
bonne santé je pense que quand les
pressés ont dû gérer avec les ARS la
crise covid ils l'ont fait je pense
qu'outre-mer quand on essaye de créer de
la valeur de créer des entreprises
l'état un grand optimiste
mais je suis un grand mais je veux faire
partager cette optimisme qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire où on est tous
communautarisés pour regarder des séries
feuilletons à la télé au lieu d'agir
mais nos enfants vos enfants ce qu'ils
attendent c'est un espoir c'est un
espoir de vivre mieux c'est un espoir de
vivre avec les autres c'est une espoir
de vivre ensemble alors c'est un livre
que vous mettez
à la République contraire c'est comment
renforcer vous racontez dans ce livre
cette vie de responsabilité parce que
c'est une énorme responsabilité qu'être
préférée notamment en matière de
maintien de l'ordre et ce jour où à 25
ans vous décidez de ne pas faire arrêter
un forfait décision que vous allez
lourdement regretter par la suite
exactement mais d'abord il faut
apprendre il faut apprendre et surtout
c'est Valérie qui disait ordre des
ordres sont les deux dangers qui
menacent le monde être ferme sur l'ordre
public ça veut dire aussi accepter ne
pas accepter la dictature c'est pas on
n'est pas dans un pays où l'ordre
commence
jeune peut-être pour des responsabilités
réfléchir à ce que c'est d'être au
milieu des autres ce type là il était
haï de par tout le monde
et donc
peut-être qu'on a à ce moment là j'ai
trop aimé les gens
parfois le préfet et la cible de
critique ça a été le cas de votre
collègue Didier l'Allemand qui était
préfet de police c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose hein préfet de police de
Paris il a confié d'ailleurs un peu
comme vous sa trajectoire c'est ses
mémoires dans un livre il raconte son
angoisse notamment au moment du
mouvement des gilets jaunes ou un
dérapage était possible et où les forces
de l'ordre ils le redoutaient aurait pu
faire feu il a traversé une période très
compliquée jusqu'au stade de France on a
été trop dur avec lui bien sûr qu'on a
été trop dur avec lui bien sûr que il a
essayé de faire son métier il n'y a pas
eu il y a eu le minimum de dégâts face à
des gens qui voulaient détruire la
République je dis pas qu'ils avaient
tort ou raison c'est pas le sujet du
moment mais mais ces gens là étaient
d'un communautarisme violent et la
République ne peut pas le supporter
alors il faut le faire avec mesure il
faut le faire avec discernement mais mes
préfets c'est ça servir les autres
c'est affronter la mort qui affronté la
mort c'est ça le plus dur je pense c'est
de voir des morts violentes des
moringuste des morts brutales et là qui
on va chercher on va chercher le préfet
les élus viennent chercher le préfet je
me suis rendu en Guadeloupe je suis à la
tempête Fiona on m'attendait
c'est ça qui est important c'est croire
que quelqu'un
depuis 1802
représente le vivre-ensemble et le vivre
ensemble avec son côté perspectif son
côté immédiat son côté rassembleur c'est
vrai que vous les Narc vous avez d'abord
fait HEC c'est là que vous avez
découvert le service public est souvent
à l'aidant on dit oh là là il faut être
bien classé sinon on va finir préfet et
vous c'est tout le contraire vous avez
adoré cette fonction vous avez beaucoup
travaillé avec Jean-Loup Borloo vous
avez dirigé son cabinet la page est
tournée Jean-Louis Borloo a pardonné à
Emmanuel Macron
je vais pas rentrer dans leur débat je
sais qu'il faut soyez nommé
m'a fabriqué dans la mission nationale
en tant que directeur de cabinet pendant
5 ans dans plusieurs ministères donc
jamais je n'oublie effectivement et on
se voit on se souvient de la dureté avec
laquelle le président avait rejeté son
plan banlieue il l'avait d'ailleurs fait
savoir à l'époque l'outre-mer parlons-en
un peu l'outre-mer subit de plein fouet
l'inflation il y a toujours eu des
problèmes de vie chère en outre-mer
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce que la
métropole fait pour une inflation qui
est à 7% en moyenne Guadeloupe
Martinique là où la métropole frôle avec
les 6%
ça dépend d'abord de quel qu'est-ce
qu'on met il y a les avions c'est un
sujet d'abord la l'outre-mer c'est
d'abord ce que je dis une chance pour la
France une chance pour c'est l'outre-mer
qui est une chance pour la France et la
France doit être une chance pour notre
mère donc il faut qu'on arrive à
construire là aussi sur un petit
territoire loin de tout à 20 000 km
imaginez ce que c'est que ça Martin
imaginer des petits territoires les
territoires australes et antarctiques
seule la République me semble-t-il peut
leur permettre de vivre ensemble mais ce
service de l'outre-mer
c'est j'allais dire le
condensé d'une vie préfectorale le
condensé d'une vie préfectoire s'est
servi en Calédonie j'ai servi en
Guadeloupe servi à Saint-Pierre
à lire votre livre je voudrais que tout
le monde les aime merci Monsieur le
Ministre Merci à VOUS préfet de la
République aux éditions du Serge
Jean-François caraco je vous propose de
rester avec moi encore quelques minutes
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ce soir
vu du perchoir avec Elsa mondingava une
ministre accusée de conflits d'intérêt
Agnès Pagny runaché qui s'est défendu
vous l'entendrez dans l'hémicycle tout à
l'heure Jean-Rémy Beaudot va nous dire
pourquoi l'état de nos armées est
inquiétant à la veille de la revue
stratégique du chef de l'État puis la
carte blanche à la féministe Léa
chamboncelle sur la riposte des
influenceuses victimes de
cyber-harcèlement nous affranchis les
voici bonsoir à tous les trois bonsoir
bienvenue à vous on commence avec vous
Elsa pour la chronique parlementaire cet
après-midi séance de questions au
gouvernement autour de laquelle la
ministre de la transition énergétique
Agnès panier relâchée a été sommet de
s'expliquer oui Myriam depuis ce matin
la ministre est mise en cause dans un
article du site internet disclose le
média dépendant a révélé que ses enfants
départs dans une société une société
créée par leur grand-père Jean-Michel
ruacher le père donc d'Agnès renacher
selon le média et bien c'est fonce on
liés à la société Pérenco pour lequel il
a longtemps travaillé et il pourrait
avoir été domicilié dans des paradis
fiscaux évidemment et bien la ministre
elle était très attendue cet après-midi
sur le sujet lors de la séance de
questions gouvernement effectivement ça
n'a pas loupé il y a trois députés de la
nuque qui ont abordé le sujet c'était
pas concerté nous urt-il toujours est-il
que socialiste insoumis et écologiste
ont demandé des comptes à la ministre ce
qu'elle a fait à la fois bien sûr les
faits mais aussi dans un registre un peu
plus personnel écoutez
en 2016 mon père a souhaité préparer sa
succession par une transmission directe
assez petits enfants cette transmission
a eu lieu par le biais d'une entreprise
française soumise à la fiscalité
française par acte notarié établi à
Paris et dans le plein respect des
dispositions applicable par la loi
française il y a donc rien de dissimulé
rien de cacher mon père ma mère et mes
enfants n'ont pas choisi une vie
publique je l'ai choisie je la conduis
en pleine transparence sur mes avoir
comme sur mes intérêts et dans le
respect de la loi voilà donc pour la
réponse de la ministre la première
ministre elle aussi a répondu à l'une de
ces trois questions oui je vous propose
d'écouter bien attentivement sa réponse
et puis de regarder la réaction de la
ministre à la fin
si votre propos est de commenter des
articles de presse je vous dis que mon
rôle n'est pas de commenter des articles
de presse et que la ministre a déjà eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur le sujet je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
quand même plus chaleureux comme message
de soutien service plus que minimum me
confier une députée de la majorité qui
n'était pas la seule à l'avoir remarqué
c'est vrai qu'on a pas entendu le mot
soutien le mot confiance côté des
oppositions cette fois Ben se satisfait
pas du tout des réponses de la ministre
notamment quand elle précise que
légalement elle n'a pas donné des
informations sur ses enfants écouter
Cyrielle châtelain c'est la présidente
du groupe écologiste la question n'est
pas soft il y avait une obligation
légale mais il y a une obligation
déontologique il y a une obligation
éthique d'être transparent quand on a
des proches c'est à dire ses parents ses
enfants qui ont des intérêts financiers
à l'exploitation du pétrole quand on est
ministre de la transition énergétique
c'est un élément d'intérêt général et
cela constitue un conflit d'intérêt
voilà c'est vrai que selon la gauche on
est plus sur un terrain moral que légal
en tout cas la hatv la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
a ouvert une enquête ça tombe pas au bon
moment pour la ministre si tant et qui
puisse y avoir un bon moment mais elle a
une loi sur les énergies renouvelable
qui a été votée au Sénat qui a
l'Assemblée en commission à partir du 21
novembre service minimum de la première
ministre monsieur le ministre ces
choses-là moi je suis soumis à la chaîne
pvp c'est quelque chose c'est vraiment
quelque chose je trouve que j'ai
une petite maison de famille qui vaut
100000 €
dans un coin perdu il faut en écrire des
pages il faut en écrire des pâtes
je sais pas c'est en tout cas c'est
l'argent qui doit être dépensé pour
vérifier ça n'est pas la hauteur de ce
que ça gagne quand même du problème mais
l'important moi je suis assez d'accord
il faut être transparent le sujet c'est
compliqué c'est difficile mais il faut
être transparent aujourd'hui c'est la
règle parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'affaires depuis l'affaire
cahuzacs mais c'est la règle et donc
c'est une vertu Jean Rémi demain c'est
la revue nationale stratégique à Toulon
c'est le premier le chef de l'État
pardonnez-moi qui s'en charge en gros
Emmanuel Macron va donner à la fois les
objectifs mais aussi le budget de
l'armée française
au niveau c'est une question qui se pose
et c'est en filigrane ce qui s'est joué
lors d'un déjeuner qui s'est tenu
aujourd'hui au ministère de la Défense
autour de la table le ministre Sébastien
Lecornu avait convié les principaux
patrons du secteur de l'armement
Emmanuel Shiva le puissant patron la
Direction générale de l'armement était
aussi présent l'enjeu du rendez-vous
c'était que l'industrie française de la
défense monte en cadence qu'on passe
réellement dans un mode qui peut un peu
effrayer mais en mode économique guerre
ça veut dire que cette industrie
aujourd'hui ne s'est pas répondre à nos
besoins alors on a des technologies mais
tout ça ne va pas assez vite dans un
contexte de guerre dans un contexte de
compétition stratégique exacerbée entre
grandes puissances on a besoin d'une
production plus rapide et aussi
localisée en France pour accessoirement
ne pas dépendre soit d'amis soit de
potentiel ennemis le ministère de la
défense mais donc la pression sur
l'industrie pour accélérer la production
de 12 équipements prioritaires ils
demandent par exemple que les obus de
155 mm alors pour les spécialistes c'est
ceux qui servent notamment à tirer sur
les chars que ces obus soient livrés en
trois mois au lieu de 9 mois aujourd'hui
il y a aussi des efforts à faire sur les
fameux canon César dont on entend
souvent parler puisque on en a livré à
l'Ukraine avant il fallait 30 mois pour
en produire on plutôt aux alentours de
24 mois aujourd'hui bien le gouvernement
voudrait que ça fasse à 12 mois pour la
pour y arriver le l'état premier en fait
de simplifier les procédures
administratives et puis de faire des
commandes un peu moins avec un peu moins
d'options pour que tout ça soit des
productions plus massives tout ça la
France sera prête en cas de guerre c'est
toute la question en fait depuis des
dizaines d'années notre modèle militaire
est basé sur des opérations de guerre
souvent à l'extérieur et parfois avec
plus ou moins de succès Emmanuel Macron
devrait d'ailleurs annoncer demain la
fin définitive de l'opération barkhane
au Mali mais quid d'un conflit de haute
intensité comme on dit sur notre
territoire pour dire les choses
clairement que se passerait-il si demain
à nos voisins nous déclarer la guerre en
coulisse il y a parfois des doutes mais
au sommet de l'État comme au sein de
l'état-major en fait on balaye la
question pour les essais ce n'est pas
une question et bien encore ce matin il
y a eu un brief à l'Elysée l'entourage
du président prend le problème autrement
selon l'Élysée il est exclu qu'il puisse
y avoir un conflit de haute intensité
sur le territoire français car on a la
dissuasion nucléaire donc personne ne
prendrait le risque de nous attaquer ça
c'est la théorie par contre la France va
être en position de mener de pouvoir
mener des conflits sur d'autres
territoires seul ou avec une coalition
et c'est pour ça que des efforts
budgétaires vont être prolongés la loi
de programmation de finances 2023
prévoit une nouvelle hausse du budget
des armées c'est quand même la sixième
hausse de suite pour pour l'armée c'est
plus de 40 c'est presque 44 milliards
avec cet argent l'Élysée promet
d'investir massivement sur l'influence
le renseignement la cyberguerre avec cet
argent l'Élysée promet aussi de réparer
des lacunes dans les munitions dans les
drones et peut-être que d'ici quelques
années bien on se posera plus la
question de savoir si notre armette à la
hauteur
espérons le très rapidement parce que le
temps presse
moi je trouve qu'on voudrait dire ça
progresse c'est bien et je vous ai dit
un mot sur l'Europe et la guerre on
oublie qu'un Européen convaincu que
depuis 77 ans nous n'avons pas connu la
guerre dans les limites de l'Union
européenne ce n'est jamais arrivé depuis
le début de l'humanité donc à tous les
matins en guerre à tout ça juste
rappeler que c'est la première fois
depuis le début de l'humanité une aussi
longue période c'est très important en
matière de relation international ce
soir vous nous parlez des influenceuses
qui riposte après avoir été victime de
cyber-harcèlement qui sont ces
influenceuses alors elle s'appelle magla
Nathalie
Ultia bagara Jones et elles ont décidé
comme de nombreux autres streams plus
précisément que plus frimeuses que
influenceuse de dénoncer les actes de
cyberviolence dont elles sont victimes
insultes menace photo d'elle détournée
deep fake voici leur quotidien et elles
sont aussi d'ailleurs
critiquées sur la toile elles ont décidé
d'ailleurs de critiquer elle justement
un certain machisme qui règnent sur
Internet absolument elle dénonce aussi
effectivement l'inaction de certains
streamers les intéressés décrivent un
autre soi très masculin où les hommes
même lorsqu'ils sont connus pour les
actes sexy sont soutenus par d'autres
qui leur offrent de la visibilité et qui
dénoncent rarement leurs actes et comme
elle des milliers de femmes sont aussi
victimes de cyberviolence je vais
partager avec vous une expérience
personnelle je fais souvent l'objet
d'attaque sur les réseaux sociaux et à
l'été 2021 j'ai été la cible une vague
de cyber-harcèlement excessivement
violente de la part de l'extrême droite
qu'on appelle souvent la fâchosphère
j'ai reçu les centaines de messages sur
Twitter sur Facebook sur Instagram du
type j'espère que tu vas te faire violer
par un migrant ou ferme ta gueule sale
et un message plus particulier m'a
fait vraiment mais vraiment fait peur il
promenait d'un concret le jour même sur
Twitter et disait on va te retrouver
quelques semaines plus tard des injures
ont été tagués sur un mur en face de
l'immeuble où vivait ma tante et là je
dois vous avouer qu'effectivement j'ai
eu peur et que mon rapport à l'espace
public a été totalement bouleversé vous
avez porté plainte j'ai porté plainte
effectivement et le policier qui m'a
reçu m'a laissé entendre qu'il était
parfaitement impossible de retrouver les
auteurs des faits et c'est à ce type de
situation que doivent aussi faire face
les femmes victimes de cyber violence ça
peut paraître anodin et on pourrait
imaginer que les menaces sont jamais
réellement mises à exécution mais
pourtant ça peut être le cas il ne faut
rien laisser passer absolument jamais le
cyber-harcèlement concerne uniquement
les femmes non pas tout à fait néanmoins
selon une étude du yorking woman's laby
publié en 2017 les femmes en 27 fois
plus le risque que les hommes d'être
cyber harcelés et selon l'agence pour
les droits fondamentaux de l'Union
européenne dans son étude sur les
violences à l'égard des femmes une jeune
femme sur 5 déclare avoir été victime de
moi un cyber-harcèlement d'ordre sexuel
depuis l'âge de 15 ans et une
adolescente sur 4 déclare être victime
d'humiliation et de harcèlement en ligne
les super violences sont un véritable
fléau et on peut se demander comment les
autorités publiques peuvent
effectivement y répondre on sait que des
lois existent et que les victimes ont
des droits l'association féministe
contre le cyber-harcèlement adressé
l'état des lieux un état des lieux
pardon et émis des recommandations afin
de lutter de manière plus efficace
contre les cybers violences elle
préconise d’intervenir sur 5 axes
informés notamment les plus jeunes
responsabilisés former les
professionnels soigner et accompagner
comprendre et quantifier et vous
renvoyer à des plateformes en ligne
effectivement si jamais cela vous arrive
je je vous invite à aller vérifier allez
pardon prendre connaissance du guide
développé par l'association féministe
contre le Séba harcèlement qui est
disponible sur Internet merci Léa merci
pour ce parti pris vous aimez Twitter ou
pas vous avez 5 secondes monsieur petite
personnelle il y a un tweet pour le
compte du ministère pour un truc vous en
méfiez
c'est toute la bagarre contre la
violence quelle qu'elle soit la violence
sexiste la violence par les réseaux il
faut combattre la violence merci
Monsieur le Ministre préfet de la
République Jean-François caraco c'est
aux éditions du cirque merci les
affranchis très belle soirée
documentaire qui commence avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien bien sûr comme
chaque soir à demain
[Musique]